it's time to go plus Ultra as Deku and
crew jump into fortnite
on top of the four new skins my hero
Academia students midoriya bakugou and
uraraka along with their part-time
teacher and full-time superhero all
might the Deku smash Mythic will be
wreaking all sorts of havoc in Battle
Royale like the Dragon Ball Kamehameha
from this past summer deku's smash is a
potential Game Changer whenever someone
uses it this thing can take out a lot of
structures very quickly Builders are
going to have to be vigilant the Deku
smash Mythic in play that is if you're
playing the regular non-zero build mode
and if that's the case what is wrong
with you Deku smash comes from two
sources like fortnite did with the
Dragon Ball collab my hero Academia will
have its own all might supply drop that
will give you the Mythic for free and
you'll also find new mha branded vending
machines that will let you buy it with
gold bars the hero training gym built by
Zen creative in fortnite Creative is a
team deathmatch mode in which you battle
over control points called rescue zones
sure you're playing fortnite today but
what future multiplayer experiences lie
in store for you well we just learned of
one more as Gorilla Games confirmed that
the long rumored Horizon multiplayer
game is indeed real and they're Staffing
up for it today in a tweet Gorilla game
states that quote a new internal team is
developing a separate online project set
in Horizons Universe featuring a new
cast of characters and a unique stylized
look friends will be able to explode the
Majestic Wilds of horizon together the
studio also expresses that they are
continuing to create single player
titles starring Eloy this multiplayer
Horizon game is also different from the
rumored Horizon MMO in development at
ncsoft the studio has expertise in the
genre as it's behind the lineage and
guild war franchises between an horizon
3 Horizon multiplayer game Horizon
called the mountain on psvr 2 and
Horizon MMO and a Horizon TV show I
think it's safe to say you're going to
have your fill of robots dinosaur action
over the next several years while you
wait on all those Horizon projects to
drop if you're a switch online expansion
pass subscriber you can download a few
more Sega Genesis games starting today
the four games in question are the
Beloved beat em up Golden ax2 sci-fi
Shoot Em Up alien storm The
bejeweled-esque Puzzler columns and the
hit fighting game Virtua Fighter 2.
currently the Nintendo switch online and
expansion pass encompasses 36 Sega
Genesis games including most of the
truly standout games of the system like
Beyond Oasis Castlevania Bloodlines
Contra hardcore Dynamite heady gun star
Heroes Fantasy Star 4 Rye star Sonic the
Hedgehog 2 and toejam and Earl the few
notable omissions arguably includes the
original Sonic the Hedgehog Sonic 3 and
Knuckles and at least one of the
console's iconic sports games such as
NHL 94 although considering that
Nintendo has slowly been adding to the
library it feels as if their additions
are inevitable
which my hero Academia character are you
picking to play fortnite with let us
know in the comments and we'll see you
here for more Gamespot news
[Music]